madame monsieur bonsoir voici le titre
que nous allons développer dans cette
édition la désillusion pour le 5e
anniversaire des accords d'oslo à la
hauteur des espoirs qu'avaient fait
naître le début du processus de paix
manifestation à tel aviv en bosnie après
plusieurs années de guerre la vie
reprend ses droits à travers une
association de femmes qui prend en
charge notamment les enfants de la
guerre ouverture aujourd'hui de la
chasse dans 45 départements français le
petit gibier pour les premiers jours un
million et demi d'adeptes en france est
plus que partout en europe au théâtre
une journée particulière tiré du célèbre
film d'ettore scola le droit à la
différence dans l'italie fasciste mise
en scène de jacques weber qui joue aux
côtés de françoise fabian que nous avons
le plaisir de recevoir ce soir
l'histoire retiendra la poignée de main
entre itzhak rabin et yasser arafat mais
cinq ans après que reste-t-il des
accords d'oslo le processus de paix
moribond hier soir des milliers
d'israéliens de l'organisation la paix
maintenant manifesté à tel-aviv
jérusalem charles enderlin la signature
solennelle à washington de cette
déclaration de principe devait marquer
le début d'une nouvelle ère
au proche orient la fin du conflit
israélo-palestinien vieux de 70 ans
aujourd'hui il faut bien dire que cet
espoir est sérieusement remise en
question
les événements des dernières 24 heures
sont là pour le prouver
cet après midi par exemple dans un camp
de réfugiés près de bethléem
des manifestants palestiniens défilaient
avec le cercueil des apports 2 en début
de matinée à jérusalem l'extrême droite
israélienne réclamaient l'arrêt des
négociations avec les paris
hier soir à tel-aviv
quarante mille personnes participèrent
un mythique du mouvement la paix
maintenant
sous le slogan netanyahu démission au
même moment le premier ministre
conseiller à la gauche israélienne de
manifester plutôt contrat parce qu'ils
disent est il n'applique pas les accords
ne lutte pas contre le terrorisme
islamique
pourtant quelques heures plus tôt à gaza
la police palestinienne avait dispersé
manu militari un attroupement du ramage
tout cela alors que le médiateur
américain dennis ross ne parvient pas à
relancer le processus de paix moribond
pour shimon peres le responsable c'est
monsieur netanyahou vraiment des ailes
actuelle c'est comme une pomme qui pond
les morts en place
def la situation risque encore de se
détériorer après la mort des deux chef
de sa branche militaire leur famas
menace de commettre des attentats
sanglants en israël
la sécurité a été considérablement
renforcée aux états unis la sphère
levinsky game le terrain politique en
tête le vice président américain al gore
apporte son soutien bill clinton
relayé par les derniers sondages qui
conforte la popularité du président la
maison-blanche riposte par la
publication d'un rapport à destination
du congrès et sur le terrain même les
démocrates font campagne puisque les
élections ont lieu dans un peu moins
d'un mois à washington philippe gassot
ce qui a troublé les américains ces
dernières heures c'est ça le vice
président al gore qui monte sur le ring
je ne crois pas dit il que le rapport va
faire changer d'avis les américains l'
affaire lewinsky passe pratiquement en
boucle sur les plus importantes
télévision du pays
mais en dehors de la tournée du pardon
du président ou la maison blanche réagit
et répond à chacune des accusations de
canettes d'art par un document qui a été
déposé au congrès pour des vip kenndal
qui assure la défense agitaient autant
debout avec autant de détails
ça n'est pas innocent le rapport star et
plein de description et de détail qui ne
sont pas indispensables et ceci n'a rien
à voir avec les charges retenues si tout
cela est mentionné c'est bien pour nuire
au président prétendre que kenneth starr
a voulu abattre politiquement bill
clinton c'est ce que va s'efforcer de
plaider la maison blanche
il ne faut pas oublier qu'il ya en ce
moment une campagne électorale pour le
congrès et pour la mairie de washington
qui risque bien d'être troublé il ya eu
50 millions de dollars ou plus d'engagés
pour faire tomber cet homme
je suis sûr que très peu d'entre nous
pourrait passer au travers quelque chose
qu'il a commis deux pas très bien dans
le passé ou ailleurs en fait le
président est très bon pour la sécurité
publique
il dit aussi des choses très
intéressantes à propos de l'éducation de
la sécurité à l'école des cent mille
professeurs supplémentaires
voilà quoi je parle le dimanche matin
harold fait campagne dans les églises
du côté des électeurs il ne semble pas
pour le moment qu'ils aient changé
d'avis allez vous continuer avec clinton
ce continuel soutenir pourquoi parce que
c'est un bon président bien sûr je vais
voter pour lui parce qu'il a fait du bon
travail
je pense qu'ils ont encore beaucoup de
monde qui soutient les ignore nous
sommes donc bien sur un terrain
politique et bill clinton toujours haut
dans les sondages ne manque pas de
rappeler son bilan positif que personne
ne lui conteste certes il ne sera pas
jugé par les américains ni par les
sondages mais si sa cote reste élevée
il risque bien de paralyser pour un bon
moment ceux qui veulent sa perte
il nous le disait en effet les
différents sondages diffusés hier et
aujourd'hui démontre qu'en ce moment
même une majorité d'américains pensent
que le président doit aller jusqu'au
bout de son mandat
reste que les réactions sont très
diverses après le choc qu'a provoqué sur
place la diffusion du rapport du
procureur star impressions recueillies à
new york par dominique derda sur les
murs de times square chaque affiche
chaque panneau publicitaire semble
adresser à bill clinton
comme un clin d'oeil complice
et alors qu en lettres de feu s'étale
sous les regards les détails les plus
intimes de sa liaison avec monica
levinsky les passants de hasard
paraissent pour la plupart regrettait
qu' au fil des épisodes on est réduit en
miettes l'honneur d'un président
vous savez moi aussi je mentirais pour
ne pas que ma femme le sache il a fait
ce qu aurait fait n'importe quel type
qui trompe sa femme il s'en trouve même
certains plus rares mais véhément qui
plutôt que d'accabler celui qu'ils ont
élus s'étonnent que l'innocence
stagiaires sentir à si bon compte
c'est qui cette monica qui osent s'en
prend dans notre président elle redit
lui dire non pour qu'il reste pure pour
le bien de notre pays
à l'angle de broadway de la 42e rue
ladoux walt disney a chassé les
dernières prostituées personne n'a
oublié que d'autres présidents ont tué
en leur temps de tori d'aventuré chacun
se souvient de mensonges bien plus
graves que ceux de l'infidèle ce n'est
pas la même chose qu'avec un seul qui
mentait pour couvrir un véritable
scandale et qui faisait du tort à
l'amérique toute entière
lui il n'a fait du tort à personne sauf
à sa femme
mais à l'heure où la police embarque
sans ménagement un petit détrousseurs de
touristes ces étrangers ces provinciaux
qui marchent nez en l'air
au sortir d'un théâtre ou d'un dîner
d'affaires on croise l'un de ceux qui
n'accordent pas vivre clinton ni la
grâce ni le pardon pour moi il ne peut
plus diriger le pays car à mon avis plus
personne ne le croira jamais surprendre
là il faut être moral pour être un chef
et il ne l'est plus dans la ville qui ne
dort jamais les secrets les plus sombres
voyage dans limousine ou se camouflent
dans de grands sacs poubelles la lumière
crue des néons ne sourit à personne ni
aux humbles ni au président et puis tout
à l'heure jacques chirac a téléphoné au
président américain auquel il renouvelle
toute son estime et son amitié dans
l'épreuve personnel qu'il traverse fin
de citation en bavière l'élection qui a
valeur de test pour l'affrontement
électoral qui doit opposer d'ici quinze
jours helmut kohl à gerhard schröder
donnent largement favori le parti du
chancelier allemand
les résultats qui viennent de nous
parvenir établissent 52% des voix à
l'union chrétienne sociale la cso contre
30% à l'opposition sociale-démocrate
près de neuf millions d'électeurs
étaient concernés par ce vote et nous
retrouvons direct de munich qu'olivier
lerner à n'en pas douter ces résultats
sont plus qu'encourageants pour une
loutre hull qui était plutôt malmenée
ces dernières semaines
l'ua trice helmut kohl doit être rassuré
ce soir en regardant la télévision de
son bureau à bonn là c'est sous le parti
frère de la cdu ou se maintient et la
gauche le spd ne progressent pas alors
ce qu'il faut dire c'est qu'il s'est
passé quelque chose d'assez particulier
en bavière ces dernières semaines on a
fait savoir à helmut kohl qu'il était
indésirable jugé indésirable sur ses
terres du sud de l'allemagne
théo vagal le ministre de l'économie et
une minute holder le ministre président
de bavière
et bien non non pas prononcé le mot
d'helmut kohl durant
nombreux meetings ici en bavière et
helmut kohl n'est venu que cette fois
ici alors que gerhard schröder a tenu
plus d'une trentaine de réunions donc
helmut kohl ne doit pas crier victoire
ce soir
si la bavière reste le fief le bastion
des conservateurs de la droite
eh bien elle s'est largement passé des
propos tenus par helmut kohl alors que
va-t-il se passer maintenant à bien
écouter
je crois qu'on va assister à une
extraordinaire dernière ligne droite les
élections en général c'est dans quinze
jours c'est pour le 27 septembre c'est
gerhard schröder le candidat
social-démocrate qui fait la course en
tête depuis des semaines maintenant il
est toujours donné gagnant pour ces
élections
cela dit il reste plus de 40 % d'indécis
en allemagne autrement dit le suspense
reste entier on ne peut pas citer ce
soir le nom du futur chancelier
merci les dernières pensées précision
politique française avec la rentrée de
charles pasqua qui réunissait en
camargue de son mouvement demain la
france à nouveau en croisade contre le
rôle l'ancien ministre de l'intérieur
évoque la menace d'une liste séparée aux
élections européennes
jacques cardoze charles pasqua a une
faim de loup un appétit à la mesure de
ses exigences politiques car au menu de
la saison qui s'ouvre les élections
européennes risque de tenir pour lui une
place prépondérante
alors pasqua repart en croisade contre
l'euro à quelques semaines du débat sur
le traité d'amsterdam
la croyance aveugle dans l'euro me
rappelle exactement la vénération qui
entourait la ligne maginot
vous n'auriez pas trouvé vous n'auriez
pas trouvé un homme politique français
en 1938 encore pour douter de
l'invincibilité qu'elle nous
garantissait seul un jeune colonel de
gaulle s'époumonait en pure perte et
charles pasqua continuera donc de
s'époumoner
car selon lui l'euro n'est pas de taille
à servir de bouclier face à la
mondialisation
le sénateur des hauts-de-seine exige un
référendum à défaut un débat qu'il
entend mener après la révision de la
constitution donc lors des élections ce
que je souhaite ce que je de marne même
ce que j'exige c'est que ce débat devant
les français aient lieu et la seule
réponse que je puisse faire à votre
question est celle-ci si ce débat n'a
pas lieu à l'occasion la révision de la
constitution
il aura lieu lors des européennes
d'autre part au nord vous avez compris
j'ai très bien compris ce n'est ici un
secret pour personne charles pasqua
lancera bien sa propre liste aux
européennes une liste sur laquelle
pourraient figurer à la fois philippe de
villiers ou des écologistes indépendants
mais le numéro deux du rpr n'exclut pas
non plus la présence de personnalités de
gauche
des représentants du mouvement des
citoyens étaient présents ici ce
week-end la fin de la fête de l'humanité
à la courneuve après dominique strauss
kahn hier c'était au tour de françois
hollande aujourd'hui de prendre la
parole à robert hue qui réaffirme que le
gouvernement doit aller plus loin plus
vite
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste répond nous ne demandons pas
aux communistes d'être sur nos positions
françaises d'abidjan père pasteur
allez on y va
le rythme et la profondeur des réformes
sociales c'est la pomme de discorde
entre socialistes et communistes qui
voudraient bien que le changement aille
plus vite et plus loin
pour autant le parti communiste et au
gouvernement
il entend bien y rester évidemment sans
perdre son identité
on essaie de croix de laisser croire qu
il y aurait que deux attitudes possibles
pour pour le parti communiste soit de
s'aligner dans une sorte de nébuleuse
social-démocrate derrière le parti
socialiste ou alors de se replier façon
secteur groupusculaire ce n'est ni l'un
ni l'autre le parti communiste a sa
place dans la gauche plurielle
il entend dynamiser cette gauche
plurielle si l'un ou l'autre des
composantes pas simplement la composante
communiste était plus là il n'aurait
plus la majorité pour y associer à autre
chose et nous on a envie de rester dans
cette configuration ministre communiste
à ses côtés brochette de dirigeants
l'entourant robert hue à souhaiter
donner des gages à ceux des militants
qui lui reprochent de trop faire de
concession au parti socialiste il a
aussi voulu donner une nouvelle
définition de son parti
il sera offensif ouvert et solidaire
élection hier et aujourd'hui en bosnie
pour la deuxième fois depuis la fin de
la guerre 92 95 des électeurs ont
renouvelé leurs instances dirigeantes la
bosnie meurtri par des années de combat
la ville tente de reprendre ses droits
grâce à l'initiative notamment d'une
association composée essentiellement de
femmes elles ont à tout cela mis en
place une structure thérapeutique qui
accueille les femmes et les enfants de
la guerre bernard lebrun philippe
turpault les enfants de la guerre ont
retrouvé le sourire et leur jeu les
filles se balancent les garçons se
battent dans la banlieue de tuzla aux
maisons à peine reconstruite est né ce
havre de paix une affaire de femmes
évidemment l'idée est venue d'allemagne
là où des milliers de réfugiés
bosniaques converger le plus souvent des
femmes et des enfants seulement les
accueillir c'était bien les soigner sur
place
ce serait beaucoup mieux c'est ainsi que
le centre vivent à djenné vivent les
femmes en bosniaque fut créée en 1994
ici parce qu'à tout cela arrive les
routes de srebrenica gorazde forniquent
fautsch à jay pas les tristement fameuse
enclave de l'est de la bosnie
dans la torpeur de l'été 1995 la
communauté internationale perdait son
honneur en laissant les forces serbes
épuré ethniquement srebrenica une
formule pour un massacre sur trente
mille musulmans
combien ont pu échapper à l'enfer on
l'ignoré encore des milliers de femmes
ont été expulsés
quant aux hommes on ne les a jamais
revus c'était il ya trois ans seulement
les enfants du centre de psychothérapie
apprennent ici à vivre sans peur ni
grand frère ou un grand père fatima 25
ans réfugiée de srebrenica est ici
depuis deux ans avec sa fille en
traitement la guerre dit elle lui a volé
sa vie et son mari disparu il après le
chemin à travers la forêt l'agent de la
chute de srebrenica
depuis je n'ai plus aucune nouvelle ni
de lui ni de mon père des autres je n'ai
plus qu'un seul frère c'est tout ce qui
reste des hommes de la famille pour
certaines on les a tuées c'est ce que je
conseille un ou deux ans je pensais
qu'ils étaient vivants quelques retards
prisonniers maintenant je sais qu'ils
ont été assassinés par les dires
s'exprimer pour évacuer la douleur c'est
la volonté des médecins qui oeuvrent
dans cette maison aux très faibles
moyens
tout comme le travail des femmes au
jardin pour améliorer l'ordinaire mais
surtout pour apprendre à gagner sa vie
et son indépendance
un long apprentissage là où autrefois
l'homme tenait les cordons de la bourse
plus de 500 femmes et 250 enfants ont
fait un séjour à vie va s'gêner c'est
beaucoup et peu à la fois parce qu'un
million trois cent mille bosniaque
vivent toujours en exil et que quatre
ans de guerre ont tué plus de 250 mille
hommes est frappé du deuil
autant de familles un travail titanesque
reste à accomplir
et pour ce bonheur retrouvé il faut que
vive vive est gêné massacres en algérie
neuf personnes tuées et six autres
blessées hier et aujourd'hui dans quatre
attentats imputés à des groupes
islamistes armés il s'agit là des
premiers attentats depuis l'annnonce de
la démission anticipée de liamine
zeroual en france l'ouverture de la
chasse aujourd'hui dans 45 départements
un million et demi d'adeptes les plus
nombreux d'europe
mathieu chez par mois minimum dix corps
se serrent n'a pas de souci à se faire
en tout cas pour aujourd'hui
pour leur rentrée ces chasseurs ont jeté
leur dévolu sur le sanglier dans les
plaines les rabatteurs et la meute dans
les collines les chasseurs aux aguets
suivent à distance grâce aux cors de
chasse
ça peut passer le temps ça fait passer
le temps et je pense avec un petit
quelque chose quoi beaucoup
somme de 38 hectares dans les bois mais
si la saison s'annonce bonne pour les
amateurs de gros gibier jacques et ses
copains girondins sont plus inquiet le
gibier à plumes se fait rare pour
pallier le manque 1000 volatiles sont
lâchés chaque année dans ce village le
plaisir n'est pas le même et qu'on se
sait ce qui est bon signe ça se fait
parce que la preuve a changé parce qu'on
n'a pas protégé suffisamment vous ont
fait tous les chasseurs sont conscients
de ça oui beaucoup
les trois quarts la cause de cette
disparition en effet la transformation
du paysage avec l'agriculture moderne
les et les bosquets ont été rasés
détruisant du même coup les refuges
naturels des faisans et perdreaux à la
rochelle plus de 500 bateaux exposés sur
quarante mille mètres carrés le rendez
vous incontournable des plaisanciers
pour cette 26e édition du grand pavois
de la rochelle a marché en pleine
expansion christophe valant bras et
alain margot malgré un ciel un peu gris
le grand pavois a le moral au beau fixe
cette année le salon nautique de la
rochelle célèbre une excellente reprise
du marché français de la plaisance après
quelques années difficiles
les ventes ont explosé au premier
semestre 98 22 pour cent de mieux que
l'an dernier
les particuliers se décide enfin à
concrétiser leurs rêves et à investir et
la variation
deux cabines c'est à dire en avant en
arrière on est dans un secteur que très
réactif c'est à dire c'est un secteur où
quand les gens n'ont pas le moral
le premier achat qui diffère c'est un
bateau puis l inverse quand les gens le
moral quand il croit un petit peu en
l'avenir quand ils sentent que ce qu'il
faut on peut se permettre de faire cet
achat est bien le bateau est un achat
qui se fait relativement bien
l'industrie française est très présente
sur ce secteur elle était prêt à réagir
elle a su répondre à la demande sans
trop de délais et quand les
constructeurs vendent les sous traitants
travaillent certains ont même dû
embaucher cette année pour répondre à la
demande
ils sont venus en masse au grand pavois
satisfaire la curiosité des visiteurs
massé de présenter la difficulté
et moi je peux également vous arrêter
complètement henry 10 ans d'autant plus
mais ça ne sera jamais bloquée arrive un
moment où le faux mots et à hauteur de
l'oraison tout affairé à ce moment là on
regarde la dent minutes
côté bateaux quelques nouveautés à
découvrir cette année comme la gamme des
trolls heures des catamarans à moteur
élégant et confortable
et puis une bonne idée a essayé à la
rochelle il est allé bateau écolo à
propulsion électrique
le gros avantage du bateau électrique
cette saison effectivement ça fait
produire en passant par murray n'importe
qui le prendre au chaos cas
le lundi dernier à l'opposé de ces
nouvelles technologies l'une des grandes
tendances de ce salon c'est le retour à
la tradition et aux bateaux en bois qui
ont une histoire qui raconte des choses
qui incorpore un matériau qui blessent
qui est confortable qui est le grand
pavois de la rochelle se poursuit
jusqu'à dimanche prochain
plus de 500 bateaux à visiter pour
investir ou tout simplement rêver un peu
en angleterre on n'en finit pas
d'évoquer le rachat possible de
manchester united par le géant de la
finance de la presse rupert murdoch les
supporteurs du club mythique du foot
anglais ont du mal à accepter que même
pour 5 milliards de francs ont vendu
leur équipe
etienne leenhardt l'autre soir sous les
fenêtres du stade de manchester united
les supporteurs du plus prestigieux club
de football anglais n'ont pas mâché
leurs mots
la perspective de voir leur club tombé
dans l'escarcelle de l'homme d'affaires
rupert murdoch transformé pour
l'occasion en diable rouge ne les
enchante guère rupert murdoch
le voici contrôle 40% de la presse
britannique et le patron de sky la
principale télé par câble détentrice des
droits de retransmission du football
anglais bref pour les supporter un
dangereux en veille chez monsieur
murdoch peut acheter impunément ceux qui
le souhaitent en amérique ou dans le
reste du monde mais il ne prendra pas
manchester ou feront tout pour bloquer
ce rachat car si nous ne le faisons pas
ce sera la fin de l'indépendance de
manchester united face à la colère des
supporteurs l'implacable réalité des
chiffres à l'image de cet entrepôt géant
à peine assez grand pour stocker tous
les produits dérivés du club manchester
united est une énorme machine à
engranger des bénéfices
le club le plus riche du monde coté en
bourse depuis sept ans et qui dégage
notamment grâce à la vente de ses
casquettes tee-shirts et bibelots à
l'éffigie de l'équipe près d'un milliard
de francs de bénéfice annuel
60000 spectateurs assistent à chaque
rencontre bref une poule aux oeufs d'or
qui depuis quelques jours a même sa
propre chaîne de télévision
le sport n'y ait plus qu'un prétexte et
les hommes de murdoch qui pourront
désormais se vendre et se racheter à eux
mêmes les retransmissions des rencontres
le jour à leur équipe
le reconnaisse publiquement sky et
manchester sont les meilleurs de leurs
lits chacun dans sa spécialité
ensemble nous avons la possibilité de
monter une affaire formidable pour le
21e siècle c'est sur le terrain que
risquent de se rejoindre les intérêts
des deux camps pour que la sphère soit
rentable il faut que l'équipe gagne et
si l'équipe gagne les supporters seront
contents l'autre soir après une victoire
4 buts à 1 tout le monde avait oublié
murdoch qui n'attend plus désormais que
l'autorisation du conseil de la
concurrence pour faire entrer le
football anglais
dans le 21e siècle yannick noah a décidé
d'abandonner ses fonctions de capitaine
de l'équipe de france pour la coupe
davis et de la fed cup
apparemment son intention de s'installer
à new york avec sa famille serait à
l'origine de cette décision concernant
le nom de son successeur il pourrait
s'agir de guy forget qui n'a pas encore
donné sa réponse en formula l'éclatante
victoire de schumacher sur le circuit de
monza le circuit fétiche des ferrari une
revanche pour le coureur allemand qui
revient à égalité avec mika qui mènent
leur en frédéric bolley triomphe d'un
homme schumacher et d'une équipe ferrari
à monza un dimanche rouge est un
dimanche de bonheur et pourtant
schumacher au départ perd gros aquitaine
de la deuxième ligne se faufile entre
l'allemand et bein euh c'est très chaud
un peu limite peut-être mais ça fasse
pour le finlandais qui pensent qu'à un
fil plus dur il est en tête sourire chez
mclaren cars coulthard mêmes deuxième
mais première alerte pour acquis naine
au 7e tour c'est justement coulthard qui
lui passe devant alors schumacher
attaque car c'est évident à kinnen n'est
pas impérial 13e tour nakano abandonne
moteur ford en feu images spectaculaires
qui en annonce surtout une autre au même
endroit deux tours plus tard coûte art
se rangent coup de théâtre le moteur
mercedes du leader a également rendu
l'âme
derrière c'est aussitôt la bagarre entre
les deux ténors du championnat
hakkinen schumacher le duel est enfin là
à mains nues ou presque c'est finalement
schumacher qui s'imposent
du coup c'est chez ferrari termine ah
bon
que l'on sourit 30 tours plus tard rien
n'a changé ou presque
schumacher et aquitaine ont observé un
arrêt aux stands le finlandais cravache
pour revenir
il n'est qu'à trois secondes de la
ferrari quand il part à la faute une
glissade à l'envers impressionnant ce
qui semble ne jamais finir
akin haine qui ne touchent rien il a de
la chance il peut repartir
mais le sort du grand prix est
définitivement scellé hakkinen seulement
4e à l'arrivée du coup avec cette 33e
victoire schumacher revient au même
niveau que le finlandais 80 points
chacun il ne reste que deux grands prix
le meilleur scénariste n'aurait pas fait
mieux alliant plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de personnes ont assisté au
défilé de la biennale de la danse une
manifestation qui n'avait pas été
subventionné par le conseil national en
raison de l'opposition des élus du front
national mieux ce spectacle a repris ses
droits et malgré la pluie la fête du
métissage venoix gadré prises et thierry
monnier
je suis un bouc d'un coquillage qui
annonce l'arrivée de mr d'arrivée de la
méditerranée ont largué les amarres pour
un voyage de rêve
embarquez à bord de ce vaisseau habité
de marins envoûtant
c'est en méditerranée que l'on vous
convient la méditerranée thème retenu
pour cette huitième biennale de la danse
de ce défilé coloré où se mêlent les
influences fusion harmonieuse des
cultures occitanes et orientale
et si ceux ci ça sur quel pied danser
c'est qu'ils ont appris et même tout
appris car ce défilé est l'oeuvre
d'amateurs de jeunes des moins jeunes
des quartiers parfois sensibles de la
région diana
c'est une invitation au coeur de la
ville de ceux qui n'ont pas souvent la
parole est aujourd'hui peuvent
s'inscrire s'exprimer et en plus ils
vont s'exprimer avec talent à mille
danseurs et musiciens hip hop ou
flamenco tous ont travaillé tout l'été
dans leur quartier car la fête leur fait
tourner la tête
on avait peut-être applaudi une famille
pour tout le monde
c'est comme si les maquis jackson là
parce qu'être le monde lui pourrait être
le père de michael jackson
mais d'ici à 60 18 ans il est tout
simplement le vétéran et danser à votre
âge sous la pluie c'est raisonnable pour
les chauffeurs et à bien la chanson sous
la pluie qui n'a pas empêché plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de personnes
d'assister aux défis malgré la pluie
plaisir de voir tous ces enfants tous
ces jeunes tous ces gens qui
essaye de faire plaisir aux autres du
plaisir pour les spectateurs de la joie
pour les acteurs à lyon cet après midi
le bonheur était dans la au début de ce
sujet je vous ai parlé du conseil
national il s'agit il s'agissait
évidemment du conseil régional au
théâtre de la porte saint-martin se joue
la pièce tirée du célèbre film d'ettore
scola une journée particulière à mes
côtés françoise fabian qui joue le rôle
d'antonietta avec jacques weber qui
signe également la mise en scène cette
pièce se déroule dans l'italie fasciste
il raconte la rencontre entre deux êtres
de solitude qui n'ont pas le droit à la
différence
reportage william irigoyen patrick voix
il existe une vraie complicité entre
françoise fabian et jacques weber
une fois que le rideau est tombé mais
aussi et avant tout sur scène dans une
journée particulière
l'histoire d'une rencontre entre une
femme au foyer et un homosexuel
licenciés pour moeurs non conformes en
pleine italie fasciste
tous mes excuses et que ce dérangement
mais pour nous c'est comme quelqu'un de
la famille si elle s'était enfuie ce
soir c'était une tragédie il y a 20 ans
sophia loren était antonieta et marcello
mastroianni gabriel dans le film
d'ettore scola
le réalisateur situe l'action en mai 38
rome défilent devant hitler et mussolini
cette journée particulière permet aux
deux personnages devenir leur solitude
et de retrouver la dignité
quand scola m'a donné son adaptation
c'était bourré de ce qu'on appelle les
didascalies enfin des commentaires de
mise en scène qui appartenait un petit
peu qu à son film malgré lui et je me
suis dit on va enlever tout ça et on va
prendre ce texte qui laisse ou texté
reculé mais il est il est débordant de
santé de sensualité de chair de rire
l'humour au service de la dérision et de
la condamnation
pour certains spectateurs aucun doute
là-dessus locataire du troisième étage
c'est toujours les autres qui vous en
vol là j'étais vraiment et bruits de la
voir là ce soir pour moi c'est quelque
chose j'ai placé une soirée particulière
c'était une pièce très très avancé c'est
très important avec la marginalisation
des êtres le droit à la différence de
thèmes qu'ils abordent françoise fabian
et jacques weber sans forcément donner
de réponse mais en tirant chaque soir le
signal d alarme pas besoin de grand soir
une soirée particulière c'est un très
joli compliment
j'ai tout de suite envie de vous dire
que j'ai un vrai plaisir à vous recevoir
d'autant que vous faites rare dans les
médias sur les plateaux de télé comme si
on pouvait faire ce métier d'acteur avec
discrétion c'est un peu une philosophie
que vous partagez avec d'autres grands
comédiens
oui mais avec des grands comédiens jeu
j'en citerai plusieurs comme michel
bouquet comme laurent terzieff comme
maria celli maria casarès ils font des
carrières sans sans apparaître tout le
temps la télévision
je crois que c'est très très bien pour
les acteurs comiques que les acteurs qui
font un show à la télévision c'est pour
ça qu'on les demande où beaucoup aussi
mais c'est très bien que je sois là
parce que c'est agréable
c'est ce je vous trouve très agréable je
trouve le journal très agréable et en
même temps je joue donc je suis ici pour
parler justement on va on en parle est
une journée particulière évoque des
thèmes graves comme la montée du
fascisme mémo sexualité le droit à la
différence
en quoi ces thèmes sans véritablement
d'actualité aujourd'hui est pour vous
et pas seulement pour moi
malheureusement il ya une montée du
nazisme partout il ya des groupes nazis
partout il ya même des clubs nazis
partout je sais par un jeune homme qui
s'intéresse beaucoup à ça qui est un
acteur aussi très connu qui me dit que y
est extraordinaire cette montée en
province et des clubs de la vie il ya
partout en europe il ya la violence et
puis il ya aussi la la marginalité des
des homosexuels qui se croit presque
obligé maintenant de vivre dans des
ghettos où on fait un bond qui forment
les quartiers qui sont des ghettos parce
qu'il pourquoi forme-t-il des ghettos
parce que ils sont pas complètement
intégrés à la société et il ya
énormément de femmes c'est
extraordinaire parce que hier soir il a
une femme bouleversée était venu me voir
et qui m'a fait mais c'est c'est c'est
vraiment tellement vrai cette pièce est
tellement vrai il ya tellement de femmes
qui connaissent cette condition encore
alors justement vous jouer le personnage
d'une femme en murs et dans ce rôle de
mère de leurs deux familles mère au
foyer à dire que c'est une femme qui est
complètement a servi à son mari niort
quoi vous ressemblent tels que votre
parcours évidemment est très différente
heureusement non mais elle me ressemble
je ne sais pas si elle me ressemble
elle est méditerranéenne elle est
chaleureuse elle est généreuse
des qualités que je pense avoir mais en
dehors de ça je ferai pas de grands
discours ni savon ni sentencieux jusqu'à
quand jacques m'a proposé la pièce je
trouvais que j'ai accepté pour le
plaisir pour le plaisir merveilleux de
jouer à bale auteur un beau personnage
avec une équipe formidable vous avez
comme ça en tête une tirade un extrait
une phrase qui me plaît de se taire
faites nous partager mais j'en ai
tellement n'a pour me piéger tout à
l'heure peut-être virage j'étais là
parce que là vous me prenez au dépourvu
on va parler de la condition féminine je
crois que c'est un thème qui vous tient
à coeur vous êtes engagé vous êtes
battus je crois à l'époque pour
l'avortement et vous avez été une vraie
féministe
oui vous l'exemple si vous pensez qu'il
ya encore des combats mais nous y ait
encore des combats
et moi je trouve que les femmes ne se
défendent pas suffisamment le une femme
doivent être dans l'opposition
et je crois qu'on mène un bon combat
quand on est dans l'opposition
alors j'ai noté que vos personnages en
temps commun l'idée d'une forte nature
et puis ils savent se serrer les dents
est ce que vous êtes arrivé dans votre
carrière de devoir faire et c'est des
gens qui luttent pour leur survie qui
luttent pour leur dignité vous dans
votre carrière vous avez dû serrer les
dents toujours encore malgré le talent
les années le nombre de nos clients
sachent pas ça n'empêche pas de toute
façon ne serait ce que pour faire des
progrès ne serait ce que pour avancer je
suppose qu'il ne faut jamais s'arrêter
et j'ai envie de toujours progresser de
toujours trouver des choses différentes
de toujours me remettre en question
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on avance
je ne crois pas que ce soit comme si on
se considère comme une institution
je trouve qu'il faut avoir beaucoup
d'humilité et puis je trouve je crois
que quand ce métier je ne le ferai plus
comme je veux je le quitterai je perds
le real a un peu le même le plus tard
possible et j'espère l'autre cas merci
d'avoir été notre invité d'avoir répondu
à nos questions cinéma encore catherine
deneuve vient de recevoir le prix
d'interprétation à venise donc le
palmarès c'est d'abord une peine qui a
obtenu prix d'interprétation il avait
déjà obtenu à cannes pour she's so
lovely lion d'or à warren beatty pour
l'ensemble de sa carrière et donc le
prix d'interprétation féminine revient à
catherine deneuve que l'on va découvrir
sur ces images
lors de la cérémonie de clôture
gadonneix
les livres la glacière pour le film de
nicole garcia placement
je dédie ce cette coupe à ma fille
chiara mastroianni et à sa soeur barbara
mastroianni merci beaucoup
ainsi se termine ce journal je vous en
rappelle le principal titre la
désillusion pour le 5e anniversaire des
accords d'oslo à la hauteur des espoirs
qu'avaient fait naître le début du
processus de paix manifestation à
tel-aviv dans un instant la météo
présentée par nathalie rihouet à 20h55
votre série urgences
demain matin dans les 4 vérités
françoise laborde eux recevra en duplex
de tel aviv bruit ça vire négociateur
des accords de sourds à 20h vous
retrouverez claude sérillon je vous
remercie de votre attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2